we could talk now to the unhcr's
representative to the UK Vicky a tenant
thank you very much being with us this
morning so MP set to vote soon on this
legislation what's your message to them
well we're very concerned that this sets
a global precedent it effectively
distinguishes the right as you've said
to to seek asylum in the UK for all but
a very few
refugees
um we know that those coming across the
channel broadly reflect the
nationalities of countries affected by
crisis by by prosecution globally so
we're talking about countries like Syria
Afghanistan Eritrea Iran Iraq Albania
several of these as I've said countries
that are producing High numbers of of
refugees so this is going to really as
as you've said it um it's in breach of
international law it's in breach of the
UK's obligations under the international
just Refugee convention just to pick up
on that United States in breach of law
um and I just want to show you the
unhcr's verdict on that legislation so
you say the bill if enacted would breach
the UK's obligations under the refugee
convention the 1954 convention relating
to the status of stateless persons the
1961 Convention of the reduction of
statelessness and international human
rights law so you're pretty clear that
they are breaching international law
what happens if that does happen will
the U.N do anything
well we work with governments and our
job is to continue to engage with um
with governments and try to find
practical Solutions practical
Alternatives and we we believe there are
practical Alternatives much more
realistic Alternatives
um that that could be pursued and indeed
to some extent are being pursued by the
government so for example we think the
the focus of attention really needs to
be on the Asylum system on Asylum
process and getting that working
properly so that people are able to
present their claims if they're not
refugees decision can be made quickly
they can be returned to their own
countries and if they are refugees then
they're able to to embark on that
integration journey and we think that's
in everyone's interests not just the
refugees interest but also the interests
of the British public so if a country is
found to be in breach of international
law what happens
well it's we work there's no sanction as
as such
um but the the the impact of that is is
quite it has an impact globally you know
we have to remember that the vast
majority of refugees are hosted in
countries neighboring their own so more
than 69 70 are in countries neighboring
their own now if you're a country like
turkey hosting more than 3 million
refugees or Bangladesh hosting you know
just short of a million refugees with
all the impact that has on your economy
on your infrastructure on your services
and then you look at a country like the
UK much further away much less impacted
many fewer refugees and that sends a
really unfortunate signal so we believe
that if this goes ahead it's going to
have a really if if other countries were
to follow suit it really would have a
very significant impact on Refugee
protection globally the government says
that look it's seeing more and more
people making this extremely dangerous
Crossing and a legal Crossing um on
small boats for the channel it's got to
do something about it
absolutely and as I've said there are
alternatives the you know we've made
recommendations two years ago to the
government on mechanisms on systems that
allow them to improve the the Asylum
processing clear the backlogs get people
through the system quickly which we
believe is absolutely key
um we're also it's also important the
dialogue with neighboring countries is
important these countries won't have
return agreements in place so what is
the UK supposed to do it has them with
countries like Albania but many other
countries it you know it's just not
practical to do that well we say that uh
you know the the the focus of attention
needs to be on getting people through
the system quickly and then on returning
those who are not in need of protection
to their own countries and that's the
that's really where the the focus of
effort needs to be okay the government
also expects to put forward plans to
start moving at migrants out of hotels
and into military bases maybe even just
used ferries what's your take on that
well clearly housing Asylum seekers in
in hotels indefinitely is not
um it doesn't make sense now essentially
the the key is that people are able to
live in accommodations to their needs
where their basic needs are met where
International standards are met but as
I've said the key really is not leaving
people in limbo indefinitely so not
having them sit waiting for decisions on
their Asylum claims indefinitely if you
can get that happening quickly a lot of
these problems costs related to
accommodation would would fall away but
I just wanted to point out as well that
under this under this bill if it were to
go ahead what you will have is people in
even more of an indefinite limbo so they
won't even be admitted to the Asylum
system in the in the first place
um so you know unless they can be
removed to to a third country and we
have a lot of concerns about how that is
being is being pursued but unless that
is the case and at the moment there are
no Arrangements that are operational
they're simply going to be here in limbo
indefinitely and that's not in anyone's
interest thanks very much coming in
interesting to get your take ahead of
that important legislation next week